[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEVIN FORD: Welcome to Cloud
OnAir, our live webinars
from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Kevin Ford.
And today, I'll be talking
about API security.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
So we have a lot to cover today.
But we're going to be looking at
an overview of the Apigee Edge
platform, which is Google
Cloud's API management
solution.
And we'll talk specifically
a lot about API security
and the things you need to
consider as an API provider.
Then I'll take
you on a deep dive
into Apigee Sense, which is a
feature of the platform that
provides bot detection and
behavior-based detection.
And then we'll go onto a demo
of that particular feature.
And then we'll move into Q&A.
So first, let's look at
a high-level overview
of Apigee Edge as a platform.
And then we'll dive into
some security features.
So one thing that we see as
a repeated pattern of success
when we work with customers is
taking an outside-in approach
with their APIs.
So traditionally, a lot of
customers traditionally--
and IT shops--
think of APIs as an
exposure problem.
Build the API, and consumers
will come and use it.
And everything will
be straightforward.
And that doesn't always happen.
What we find is that much more
successful programs end up
thinking about how to deliver
that experience to the user.
So who do we need
to enable here?
In this slide, you
see the developer.
This is the developer building
your systems of engagement,
building your
mobile applications,
your web applications.
You need to enable them
with a great API that's
consistent and
easy to use so they
can build those experiences and
iterate on them very quickly.
And you do that
with an API platform
that offers features for your
API team to move very rapidly
and respond to the
needs of that developer.
So we're going to focus on--
in the Apigee platform-- helping
with exposure but with a deeper
focus on consumability.
And that means just a great
developer experience overall.
So this is a high-level
look at the capabilities
of the platform.
It's one single,
unified platform
with a single experience
for your users.
But it can be
thought of as being
in three conceptual parts.
So API services
host your runtime.
And that manages all
your API traffic.
That's where you would apply all
the API features and policies
like traffic management and
security that we'll get into.
Developer services is
where you host a portal
as a primary feature.
And then that enables all
of the other experiences
that the consuming developer
will have when they interact
with your API program--
and then analytics
services to give you
the ability to measure the
program from end to end.
Management services
really is the foundation
on which all of them are built.
So first, API services--
here, you can see a super
high-level overview that
shows where the platform sits.
And the Apigee Edge runtime sits
in between your API consumers
and your back-end systems.
And this facade pattern allows
you to extract or abstract
a lot of the cross-cutting
concerns that you would
typically be building into
your back-end services--
things like security,
throttling, managing SLAs
with particular clients.
All of these types
of things that you
have to do for all of
your API consumers,
you move those
into the platform.
And then that frees up
your service developers
to focus on building
services that are related
to their domain expertise.
And they don't have to
worry about implementing all
those cross-cutting concerns.
So now, moving on to
developer services,
at the heart of developer
services is a developer portal.
And this is what you see if
you go to any API provider
and you want to
consume their API.
If you go to Google's
developer portal,
you'll see a listing of
all the APIs on offer.
You'll have the ability
to try them out.
You can kick the tires.
You can see
descriptions of what it
requires to interact with the
APIs and what they can do.
All of these things
make it very easy
for you to consume our APIs.
And you should be thinking the
same way about your own APIs.
Think of them as products.
And you're marketing
these products
to developers who are
going to consume them.
And especially in the case
where there are alternatives,
you need to make that a
really good experience
for those developers so that
their time to first response
is very short, often
measured in seconds.
So as an API consumer, if I go
to a portal of an API provider
and I can't within a very
small number of minutes
get a successful
response and try it out--
hopefully in a live
trial situation--
then I'll move on
somewhere else.
So having that world-class
developer experience
is really important.
Additionally, in the
developer services,
we host things inside your
portal, like a forum, blogs.
We can host SDKs--
all of the typical
things that API consumers
expect to help them leverage
your APIs and be successful.
And then finally,
analytics services--
so you've built out your APIs.
They're being
consumed, hopefully
by a lot of developers,
both internal and external.
So how do you measure the
success of your program?
How do you know which APIs
are experiencing greater
than expected latency?
Are there high error
rates for particular APIs?
Is that a problem with
your API, your API
documentation, your back end, or
is it an issue with the client?
So with Apigee
Analytics, we provide
you insights all the way
from the client consuming app
to your back-end service.
So you can see everything
along the entire chain
and be able to evaluate and make
business decisions about which
APIs to promote, which
APIs might need work,
as well as operational insights
for working on performance
and these kinds of things.
So every year, Apigee
hosts an API conference
where we share our thought
leadership on the API landscape
and API space.
And we have business
and technical tracks.
And we actually started
this year's in Sunnyvale
a couple of months ago.
And coincidentally,
today, we're wrapping up
the world tour in Chicago.
But on our technical
track, we're
always talking about the
aspects of an API program
that make us successful.
And when you look
at the actual APIs,
a lot of the things that
make them successful--
but like I mentioned
before, making them easily
consumable by
developers-- are things
like having a standard,
consistent interface.
And you get that by
applying that facade
and not leaving the interface
up to each individual service
developer.
The fact that there's a
consistent resource model
to code against--
all these things that
make APIs easy to use also
make them very easy
to use by attackers
who want to exploit
vulnerabilities
in your back ends.
So what kind of
tools do you have
if you're leveraging
Apigee in order
to combat some of these attacks?
So this picture shows
an end-to-end view
of the kinds of features
we have in place to help
protect your APIs.
Starting at the client, we have
the ability to leverage TLS--
of course, one-way or two-way
TLS-- between the client
apps and Apigee itself.
We have OAuth policies to
enable OAuth protections,
API key policies, JWT
policies all out of the box.
I'm not going to get into all
this and read this whole slide.
There's a lot of features.
But at the proxy
level, similarly, we
have access control, OAuth.
We protect the back end as
well with TLS, IP whitelisting.
And then the platform itself
has full role-based access
control, both in the platform
for your organization's users,
as well as in the
developer portal.
So when a consumer comes, they
see the right API products,
the right APIs, the
right level of access
that you want them to see.
And you may have
a different view
for the developers internal
to your organization
versus external third parties.
So all of that end to end is
all done through configuration.
There is no code.
This is configuring
features or drag and drop
with policies to do
all this enforcement.
So there are lots of attacks,
and we hear about these
all the time.
There was a pretty bad breach
just about two weeks ago
where a major social
network ended up
allowing the
harvesting of hundreds
of millions of user accounts.
So that's an attack that falls
into one of the major two
categories we see.
And there are more
categories in this,
but the vast majority
of them go into account
takeover-type attacks
and scraping attacks.
So the one I was just
discussing is a scraping attack
where a vulnerability
which allowed access
to more resources than was
intended by the platform
allowed a malicious application
to scrape far more data out
and then retain that data and
use it for its own purposes.
So all these attacks
are things that you
need to be concerned with.
And they're all
things that we're
seeing across a broad
range of our customers.
Very few of our customers that
we've evaluated and worked with
have not seen a large number
of these attacks occurring live
on their APIs.
So this is a quick graphic
here to demonstrate
a couple of the different
kinds of attacks.
And first, we're all familiar
with denial of service attacks.
And as a GCP customer,
you're already
leveraging a massive, massive
data center bisection bandwidth
in excess of 1,000
terabits per second.
So from a DoS
perspective, you're
being protected by a
cloud provider that's
able to absorb an immense
amount of traffic.
But there are other
kinds of attacks.
So if you look at here,
we've got the ability
to do volume-based
and region or blocking
based on known bad ISPs or IPs.
And that will block
your DoS attacks.
But a lot of things
will still get through
because these malicious
bot creators know
how to stay under the radar.
They know that if they send
millions of requests a minute,
this will be blocked.
They also know potentially
that you have--
because you have a developer
portal that says so--
that you allow 500
requests an hour.
So we see bot writers
creating bots that come
in at a randomized
number of requests-- say,
between 4 and 450 requests--
so it looks and blends in
with your normal traffic.
So it's important that
we have a different way
to address these
types of attacks
that look like human traffic.
So it ends up that
the security model
is very different with APIs than
it is with traditional systems
before we started exposing
our APIs in such a wide way
with external entities.
So you need protection
that's purpose-built.
And it's going to separate
the bad from the good traffic,
both from your good clients--
because for a known
partner of yours,
they'll still make bad calls.
For instance,
exceeding a quota--
we need to block that.
For instance, issuing a request
with an expired API key--
you need to block that.
But then there are all
these bad actors as well.
And this is very difficult
with those types of calls
to distinguish.
And that's where we
introduced Apigee Sense.
And this was in
response to a lot
of our customers experiencing
high volumes of bot traffic.
And they came to us and
said, this is difficult
because we have set up quotas.
We've established all
of the right things.
But those requests
are still coming in.
And although they don't
always penetrate the system,
we can see through our
analytics that they're there.
Those requests are there.
And they wanted us to
help them address this.
So how does Sense work?
So as I mentioned, it's
built specifically for APIs.
And we've leveraged
the fact that we
process trillions
and trillions of API
calls to learn what are the
bad behavioral patterns.
And this is, again,
not a deterministic,
this one particular call is
exhibiting this behavior.
It's more about over time, this
particular IP, particular ISP,
set of IPs is exhibiting
this behavior.
And that is something
that we can detect.
And it happens in a closed loop.
And it gets smarter and
smarter as you use it
and as you feed rules
into the system.
So Sense runs in the background.
And it leverages
the analytics data
that we're already collecting,
so there's very little
overhead.
We've built the
models for detection
based on our understanding
of all of our customers
on our cloud.
However, your data as an
individual Apigee customer
is never commingled with
anybody else's data,
any other customer's data.
Our tenancy model
disallows that.
But we have leveraged the fact
that we're the largest API
management platform to
gain insights about what
kinds of patterns matter and
how to protect against them.
So of note also is the
patterns that I mentioned.
And we'll look at them
in a minute in the demo.
We've established the
patterns, but they're
completely tunable by you.
So you start out with
sensible defaults,
and then you can
tune them by you.
And you can even introduce
your own rules and patterns.
So Sense operates in
two high-level phases.
There's detection
and protection.
In detection, as I
mentioned, the traffic's
analyzed in real time.
And the alerts when we
detect suspicious behavior--
and I say "suspicious."
We don't know when
we detect something
that it is bad traffic.
But we know that it
matches a pattern that we
suspect might be bad traffic.
So we issue alerts immediately
to your administrators.
And then they come in.
And they get a full
detailed report
that shows the types of
attacks that are coming in
and the behaviors
they're exhibiting.
You can dig into the logs
and analyze exactly what
the requests look like.
And that gives your
operational administrators
and your security
admins the ability
to detect or to start
thinking about how
to act on that traffic.
So that's phase one.
And I mentioned we'll
look at some of the rules.
But we have rules about
unusual error rates,
accessing a larger than expected
surface area of your APIs.
If you have a catalog, for
instance, in the retail space,
it's atypical for a
customer to access 60%
of the items in your catalog.
That would be a trigger for
a bad behavioral pattern.
So the next step is protection.
So now we've given
you this dashboard.
And we've given
you alerts to let
you know that we have suspicious
activity potentially happening.
So you'll see a dashboard
where you can then
act on all of these requests.
And you can choose--
and this is a big
differentiator here--
is you can choose to
allow that traffic
to proceed into the system.
You can choose to block it.
Or you can choose to flag it.
And this gives you a
really flexible way
of handling the traffic.
And we'll dive in a little
more into what I mean
by that flexible protection.
But last, I want just drive
home this closed loop.
So the closed-loop system
that we've implemented
does a couple of things.
One is because we're leveraging
analytics data that we already
capture anyway, we
add very little,
almost no latency to requests.
In fact, we had no
latency at all to detect.
We had less than 10
milliseconds of latency
when we are protecting.
And that's a matter of if
you want to block or allow
or flag traffic.
So it's a super-low
latency solution
because it runs in a closed
loop offline with data
we're already collecting.
And a little more on
flexible protection--
there's two things
we mean when we
talk about flexible protection.
One is what you can do.
What kind of actions
can you take?
I mentioned that you can block
traffic, you can allow traffic,
or you can flag traffic.
So what is flagging?
What that means is adding
a header, for instance,
to a request to
say, maybe I don't
want to block this immediately.
I'm aware that this is a bot.
I'm aware they're
scraping my data.
But instead of blocking them
so they can go and retool
their bot and hit
me again, I might
want to send them
a delayed response.
I might want to
manipulate the data.
I can manipulate the
data in the request.
I can send them
static pricing data.
I can dummy the data up.
I can remove fields from it.
There's all kinds of things
I can do to that data.
And that's a really
powerful tool
because the bot developers are
looking at their responses.
So sometimes, blocking
is the right choice.
Sometimes, you want to
do something specific
to handle that in a
different kind of way.
And allowing is another
important aspect
because we allow our partners
to work against our APIs
in a bot-like way.
I have many customers
who have partners
that write bots to pull
down data on a daily basis.
So that would appear to
Apigee Sense as a bot.
But your security admins can go
and allow all of that traffic
for its particular
duration or perpetuity
so that that partner is not--
its traffic is not blocked.
So the other aspect
of flexible protection
is configuration or code.
So the first that I mentioned
is how you act on your traffic.
And then the next
part is specifically
about the case where
you flag traffic.
As I mentioned, we're going to
enrich a request with a header.
That means once that request
gets into the Apigee processing
runtime, you have the ability
to do anything you like to it.
That means you can leverage
one of the nearly 40 policies
in Apigee to do
things like traffic
shaping, conditional routing.
And all of these things are
done simply by configuration.
It's a policy that you
drag into your API flow,
you tune the attributes,
and it works.
The other choice of how you
deal with flagged traffic
is through code.
And we have extension
policies that
allow you to write JavaScript,
Python, Java, or Node.js
if you want to extend the
capabilities for handling
that flagged traffic.
So it gives you a lot of
different flexible options
on how to deal with
these potential attacks.
So I have a graphic here.
And I want to talk
a little bit--
the way I think
about API security
is it's about layers of defense.
And the best analogy that comes
to mind for me is this here.
If you look at this castle--
and imagine for a moment
that the walls here
are your API policies.
Your walls are defining that
OAuth 2.0 is required to enter.
So they're going to
block those requests.
You've got some
throttling going on
because you have
this one defined
entry point with a solid door,
maybe guards in the gatehouse.
And it looks pretty secure,
difficult to penetrate.
But the problem--
there's a problem here.
The problem is all around
the castle are trees,
and there's limited visibility.
So at any moment, there
could be many attackers
under the tree line chipping
away at that brick wall.
And they may never
make it through.
But if you give
them enough time,
the odds are that they will.
So just because you've
got strong walls
and a defined entry point
doesn't completely protect you.
You need visibility.
So here's a different view.
It's a similar castle.
There's a throttling
mechanism that
brings traffic into one entry
point with a strong gate.
You've got the same walls with
the same OAuth protection,
but they have a moat.
And they've cleared
out all the trees.
So this API provider
can see for miles
as people are attempting
to come in and attack.
And that gives him the
ability to figure out
how to respond to them.
If it's a friendly
party, no worries.
You might want to
block that party.
So that's kind of the
way I think about it.
It's layers and
layers of security.
And the Sense feature that
we're talking about a few slides
back is an additional layer
beyond the DoS protection
you get in GCP, beyond
the full suite of security
policies already
offered by Apigee Edge
to handle that traffic that
looks like human traffic
or looks like friendly
traffic but is not.
And then, of course, protection.
We mentioned detect-- the
visibility helps us with that--
and protect.
So as unfriendlies
are approaching,
we know exactly how
to deal with them.
So at this time,
I'm going to jump
into a quick demo
of Apigee Sense
to show you what the
dashboards look like
and how you might
interact with them.
All right.
OK.
So what you can see right
here is the Sense dashboard.
And right now, we're on
the bot analysis report.
Let me switch into the rules and
show you what those looks like.
So I mentioned that we
have a lot of rules baked
into Sense that are designed
and actually were built based
on the trillions of API
calls that we receive
and our deep experience working
with all of our customers.
So we have things
like content quota
exceeder, OAuth collector.
I mentioned scraping.
We have content scrapers.
We have guessers.
Each one of these is combating
a particular type of bot
that generally fall
into a few categories.
But let's look at
a couple of these.
So OAuth collector-- and
you have a description here.
It's a high number
of OAuth sessions
but a small number of
user-agent families.
So here, you can define the
ranges of what's acceptable
and what's expected behavior.
Now, I can define these
ranges for that rule.
And that rule will simply
control with those new defined
parameters when suspicious
activity is highlighted
or when activity would be
highlighted as suspicious.
And I'd be alerted.
And the policies are all
similarly configured.
They have different levels
of attributes for each one
and different minimums and
maximums in their ranges.
But they all effectively
follow this pattern
where it's an established
set of attributes,
and you configure the range that
defines suspicious behavior.
You also have the ability
to create your own rules.
If there are specific attacks
that are relative to you
or you feel you
want to investigate
a particular area of concern,
you can build your own rules
as well.
The next-- I can
look at the report.
The detection report--
as I mentioned, again,
just to remind the audience,
it's about detect and protect.
And the first section, which is
where we still are right now,
is about detection.
I want to look at a report of
what's going on in my platform.
Little issue here.
Just let me refresh the page,
get in the right organization.
All right.
Here we go.
So over here, I can
see the total traffic
that's coming into my system
over this particular time
range.
And I can adjust my time range.
And I'm showing all of them.
I can filter by the
requests that are already
defined to be allowed,
blocked, or flagged,
or ones that I've
not taken action yet.
So at this point, I can
see the kinds of behaviors
that Sense is detecting.
It's detecting one guesser
bot, a login guesser,
an OAuth abuser, and
an OAuth collector.
And this is the traffic
from each of those.
I can directly act here, which
allows me to build a protection
rule to enforce a particular
action on these types
of requests in the future.
I can dig into the
details of them if I like.
I can even look at
a list view, which
shows particular requests.
This is a particular IP address,
its activity over the time
range that we've
set, and the types
of rules that it's triggering.
And here, I can also
act on it, which
will create a rule for me.
So that's the detection side.
Now, if I look at protection--
again, let's look at
the protection rules
that are already established.
And these are ones
that have already
been set based on
suspicious activity
that Sense has
highlighted to me.
So these rules
have been created.
I can add rules.
I can filter them.
And you can see
exactly the definition
and how long they are lasting.
This is a short-lived rule
that will last for a few hours.
This one will always
be there because it's
my trusted partner.
I don't expect them to change.
If they change,
I'll work with Sense
to configure the rule for them.
But I want my trusted partner
to always come through
with their friendly bot.
But I can create a rule,
and I can block traffic.
I can have it expire
whenever I like.
And I can block by bot reason.
Let's block all brute
guessers and have
that expire in 12 hours.
And yes, it's active.
Sorry-- block brute guessers.
So I've created that rule.
And from this point
forward, Sense
will automatically and instantly
enforce this blocking rule.
Now, had I made a flagging
rule, what Sense would do
is add that header
that I can then
go modify my Apigee
API to respond
to that header in
a particular way.
So that's a quick run through.
There's a lot more I could
show you of Apigee Sense
and, of course, of the
entire Apigee platform.
But in the time
we have, hopefully
I covered the end-to-end flow
of how Apigee Sense works.
So I'm going to hop back here.
All right.
Sorry about that delay.
So hopefully, this
session was informative.
Hopefully, you
learned a few things.
If you want to learn more,
there are lots of ways to do so.
So first and foremost,
Apigee offers
a free trial where you get
unlimited use of the platform.
And you can spin
up an organization,
which is the high-level
Apigee unit of tenancy.
You can think of
it as your company.
And you can spin that up
in a matter of seconds.
And you can then go ahead
and create API proxies
and start proxying your
own services or third party
APIs in no time.
We have hands-on
enablement as well.
There is a virtual API jam.
It's a video
instruction course where
you'll have an
instructor lead you
through a series of
labs and workshops
that take you through the
end-to-end journey of an API
provider.
And we also offer
on-site API jams, where
we do a similar thing
but we come to you
or invite you to one of
our offices with your team,
and then product demo webinars
like this one and others.
We've got a lot of
features covered.
And we're going to continue
to cover more features based
on the feedback we get from you
all to these types of sessions.
So stay tuned for live Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute.
Welcome back.
So I wanted to do a quick recap
before I jump into the Q&A.
We covered Apigee as a platform.
We talked about a lot of
the API security threats
that we see every day when
we're dealing with customers.
And this involves standard API
security policy-type things,
such as enforcing OAuth,
enforcing your AAA type
authentication, as well
as traffic management,
quota management.
We talked about
bots, both good bots
from trusted partners as
well as malicious bots,
and then what features
in Apigee Edge
allow you to address
those different concerns.
And then we drilled
down a little bit
into Apigee Sense, which is
our bot detection feature.
And I gave a quick demo
of Apigee Sense that
shows how you can detect bots
flowing through your APIs
and how you can act on
those, either blocking
traffic, allowing traffic,
or flagging traffic
for special handlings, like
redirecting to a honeypot.
So now, I want to jump
into some questions
that we've gotten throughout the
session and that are coming in.
First, what is the performance
impact of Sense on API traffic?
So I touched on this briefly.
I mentioned that Sense adds
less than 10 milliseconds.
And essentially, you can
think of this as no impact
because the detection
is all done offline.
And there's zero impact.
The less than 10
milliseconds is simply
the time it takes us to
block or flag a call,
which you would be
performing anyway
through an API policy or any
type of enforcement measure.
So it should feel
like no latency
is added at all to proxies
when you're using Sense,
to your APIs when using Sense.
Next question-- is Sense
available for private cloud?
And private cloud is Apigee's
term for on-premises.
We didn't talk about
deployment options.
But Apigee can be deployed
on the cloud where
it's fully-hosted SaaS
product or on-prem.
Or we have hybrid
options as well
and several other derivatives.
But Sense is currently
only for cloud customers.
So on-prem customers are
not able to leverage Sense.
And this has a lot to do
with the technologies we
use to power Sense
in GCP, as well
as the performance required
and the infrastructure
required in order to
run this kind of system.
So next was asked, is
Sense a separate product
or is it included
with Apigee Edge?
So Sense is a feature
within Apigee Edge.
You can talk about licensing
with your account team.
But it's a feature that's
part of the platform,
and you can leverage it as long
as you're a cloud customer.
And it is restricted to
enterprise customers.
We have different pricing tiers.
So our basic, which are
targeting lower-volume API
programs, are not able
to leverage Sense.
But all enterprise Cloud
customers have the ability
to leverage Apigee Sense.
Can Sense be added
at the proxy level?
And can you choose which
APIs flow through Sense.
So yes.
You can configure the detection
rules to be API proxy specific.
So if you only want to detect
on your OAuth endpoint,
you can configure
rules to do that.
And then protection happens
at the organization level.
Finally, does Sense
look across all customer
data to identify
malicious patterns?
So Apigee Sense-- when
we were building Sense
and as we continue to make
Sense better and smarter,
we leverage the breadth of
data that we have across all
of our customers on cloud.
But that's solely for
building the models.
That doesn't participate at all
when we're detecting traffic.
So we are leveraging
our experience
working with some of the most
major, some of the largest API
providers in the industry
to determine and feed
into the models that
allow us to surface
what are the behavioral patterns
that we should be concerned
with.
But once those
models are defined--
and we're ever
tuning those models--
those models get
applied completely
within a particular
Apigee organization.
And I touched on it,
but just to confirm,
an organization is
a tenant in Apigee.
So Apigee a
multi-tenant solution.
And your company would likely
be a single or possibly
more than one organization.
So the model is applied
to your organization.
And the detection and
protection is done solely
within the confines of that
organization, completely
sandboxed from all other
data within Apogee.
So your data is never
commingled with any other data.
All right.
So that wraps up the questions
that we received that were not
already answered individually.
So I just wanted to thank
you all for your time
and remind you to stay tuned
for the next session, which
is get the most
out of your audit
logs with these
configuration best practices,
broadcasting live from
our New York office.
[MUSIC PLAYING]